[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
richter und claus kleber
guten abend gerade werden wieder eine
neue explosion mindestens gemeldet aus
kabul dort ist der albtraum wahr
geworden heute der allen militärs
politisch verantwortlichen und vor allem
den menschen am ort von anfang an vor
augen stand in chaos dort war der terror
einfach zu leicht zu bewerkstelligen um
ungeschehen zu bleiben eine bombe
platziert in der menschenmenge vor dem
abbey gate des kabul airport brennpunkt
aller flüchtenden und eine zweite
explosion an einem der hotels in den
botschaften oder organisationen ihre
angehörigen zusammen holten für die
ausreise die zahl bestätigter
todesopfern verwundeter ist über die
letzten stunden immer weiter gestiegen
afghanistan hat seine toten noch nicht
zählen können es sind möglicherweise
mindestens 60 tote und über 140
verletzte das
us-verteidigungsministerium meldet
bisher zwölf tote in seinen
streitkräften es war und ist immer noch
in einer furchtbaren lage ein ganz
besonders furchtbarer tag möglicherweise
nicht der letzte die deutschen truppen
sind jedenfalls jetzt raus york war also
bericht
sie fliehen in panik vom tatort das
grauen kam mit ankündigung zwei
selbstmordattentate vor denen
geheimdienste seit tagen gewarnt hatten
erschüttern kabul in dem kanal neben dem
weg zum flughafen liegen tote und
verletzte
bereits am frühen morgen hatte es eine
erste explosion gegeben die opfer wurden
in die krankenhäuser der stadt gebracht
wie viele heute starben ist noch nicht
bekannt
ich wollte dorthin um ein visum nach
amerika zu bekommen im nordöstlichen
teil des flughafens dann gab es einen
mächtigen selbstmordanschlag mitten
unter den leuten viele sind tot auch
amerikaner viele sind tot und viele
verletzt
der sprecher des amerikanischen
verteidigungsministeriums bestätigte
amerikanische opfer am abend dann die
nachricht mindestens zwölf us
militärangehörige sind tot
us-medien vermuten hinter den
explosionen eine splittergruppe des
sogenannten islamischen staates es ist
ein fiasko für die internationale
gemeinschaft die vereinten nationen in
new york reagieren mit trotzigen
durchhalteparolen das große der vorfall
zeigt wie instabil die lage in
afghanistan ist aber er stärkt uns auch
in unserer entschlossenheit den menschen
in afghanistan wie dringend benötigte
hilfe zukommen zu lassen
wie aber soll das gelingen wenn die
ausländischen kräfte abziehen und die
neuen machthaber offensichtlich die lage
nicht im griff haben weil auch sie die
siegreichen taliban nicht die einzigen
sind die in afghanistan agieren
wenn irgendjemand denkt dass nur eine
gruppe afghanistan regiert liegt er
falsch dieser gedanke war schon in der
vergangenheit falsch und er ist auch
jetzt falsch das andere problem ist dass
unser land in trümmern liegt und es wird
nur gelingen es aufzubauen wenn wir alle
in einer regierung zusammenarbeiten alle
volksgruppen werden einbezogen wir
werden allen dienen
doch nur wenige vertrauen auf diese
versprechen die taliban kontrollieren
die zufahrt zum flughafen
die selbstmordattentäter aber konnten
sie nicht stoppen
dafür verwehren sie denen die das land
verlassen wollen den zugang zu den
retten den flügen
die ausländischen truppen wollen dass
wir zum flughafen kommen aber die
taliban oder ihre kämpfer lassen uns
nicht durch obwohl sie von uns alle
nötigen dokumente in den händen halten
das ist das größte problem
ein taliban-sprecher verurteilt am abend
die heutigen terroranschläge und gibt
den ausländischen truppen die schuld
sobald diese das land verlassen hätten
sagt er werde es solche anschläge nicht
mehr geben die fremden truppen beeilen
sich ergreifen die flucht aus einem land
das im chaos zu versinken droht
unsere reporterin in afghanistan katrin
eigendorf verfolgt das geschehen
inzwischen aus taschkent dem zielort der
flugzeuge die aus kabul kommen kathrin
was wissen sie über diese neue explosion
wie kabul gerade eben erst erschüttert
hat
so wie ich von meinen informanten in
kabul hat die sich in einem ganz anderen
teil der stadt ereignet nämlich in einem
viertel das überwiegend von der hasara
minderheit einer schiitischen minderheit
in afghanistan
bewohnt wird die sind eigentlich mit den
taliban das kann man sagen verfeindet
aber man geht trotzdem davon aus dass
auch dieser anschlag möglicherweise von
einem afghanischen ableger des
sogenannten islamischen staates verübt
wurde in den sozialen medien und das ist
bis jetzt noch unbestätigt das sind
wirklich nur nachrichten aus den
sozialen medien ist davon die rede dass
es insgesamt fünf anschläge jetzt gerade
gegeben hat in kabul aber da werden wir
einfach noch abwarten müssen dass das
wirklich bestätigt wird es ist eine
erneute bestätigung was für ein
unsicherer ort kabul nun geworden ist
was bedeutet da das ende der evakuierung
für die menschen die auf den westen
gesetzt haben
nun alle die da zurückbleiben und das
sind ja nicht nur die ortskräfte sondern
das sind ja auch sehr viele
intellektuelle das sind journalisten das
sind auch menschen die die doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft von vielen westlichen
staaten haben sind enttäuscht frustriert
die leute mit denen ich sprechen konnte
mit denen ich kontakt halte
verschanzen sich teilweise zu hause ich
habe vorhin noch mit einem journalisten
gesprochen mit dem ich immer wieder
kontakt habe er sagte ihr habt uns total
im stich gelassen ich kann mein haus
nicht mehr verlassen ich weiß überhaupt
nicht wohin weil es gibt jetzt gar
keinen weg mehr raus also da ist sehr
sehr viel bitternis bei diesen menschen
und im prinzip sieht keiner von ihnen
mend eine vertrauensvolle möglichkeit
das land noch zu verlassen in der tat
schwierig dankeschön kathrin und wir
wechseln zu einem anderen entscheidenden
platz nämlich nach washington zur mrt
wissen die sicherheit in kabul ist jetzt
plötzlich als ein gemeinsames interesse
der us armee und der taliban geworden
eine fast absurde situation wie wird das
in washington verkauft
iris wird hier natürlich mit großen
zweifeln an der fähigkeit des
präsidenten auch gesehen ein stück weit
weil man sich ja auf den deal mit den
taliban eingelassen hat und ein stück
weit auch darauf verlassen hat das in
einem umfeld vom flughafen die taliban
mit ihren check points die menschen
wirklich kontrollieren am ende hat es
offenbar mindestens ein
selbstmordattentäter bis direkt an das
eingangstor des flughafens geschafft wir
haben vorhin beim pentagon briefing den
zuständigen general mackenzie gehört ja
das beschrieben hat offenbar während die
us-soldaten menschen abgetastet haben
und überprüft haben unmittelbar an
diesem geld hat dann diese attentäter
die bombe gezündet offenbar handelte
sich um eine sehr große bombe aber der
general sagte eben auch das ist eine
evakuierungs mission dafür haben wir
zusätzlich sehr viele soldaten hinein
geschickt wir wussten vorher dass wir
angegriffen werden mit höchster
sicherheit wir haben uns entsprechend
vorbereitet nun ist es passiert die
opferzahlen sind überraschend hoch aber
er sagt auch ganz klar wir machen weiter
die us marines und die soldaten haben in
den letzten zehn tagen 100 4000 menschen
an diesen gates kontrolliert am
flughafen und sie wollen dass auch in
den nächsten tagen tun auch wenn man
weiterhin mit anschlägen in kabul
rechnet nun ist dass joe biden das
rückzug heute sind us soldaten gestorben
in einem krieg der schon verloren ist
wie beschädigt so etwas den präsidenten
also es wird natürlich die opposition
nutzen und ihm vorzuwerfen dass er
weitere hätte bleiben müssen dass us
soldaten weiter dort bleiben müssten bis
jedenfalls alle us-staatsbürger
ausgeflogen sind auch viele die der us
armee geholfen haben aber ich glaube es
ändert nichts an dem und leben legen
denn fakt hier in den usa dass die
überwältigende mehrheit der amerikaner
über 70 prozent der festen überzeugung
sind dass man raus muss aus afghanistan
dass dieser krieg zu ende ist das sind
dann die letzten opfer im dem längsten
krieg den amerika je geführt hat aber
ich glaube es wird an dem abzugsdatum 31
august nichts verändern bei der
präsident weiß dass die mehrheit der
amerikaner hinter ihm steht das sind
noch viele tage in den viel passieren
kann dankeschön elmar es war lange schon
klar seit die amerikaner den spätesten
endpunkt nächsten dienstag gesetzt
hatten dass der deutsche anteil der
evakuierung in diesen stunden spätestens
morgen zu ende sein würde der
terroranschlag setzte blutig heute einen
neuen punkt auf sofort obwohl noch viele
hundert afghanen anspruch gegen
deutschland auf sicherheit haben die
bundeswehr ist raus diese mission ist
noch lange nicht erfüllt andreas cüppers
nur der bundeswehr kameramann darf
drehen wie am morgen einer der letzten
deutschen rettungsflüge von taschkent
aus nach kabul startet eines der wenigen
bilder die das ende dokumentieren nur 14
sekunden dann das logo dann schluss die
verteidigungsministerien teilte am abend
mit dass nach den anschlägen eine
verlängerung der evakuierung operation
nicht möglich war
die deutschen maschinen haben sich zum
zeitpunkt der anschläge in der phase der
beladung gefunden nach den anschlägen
wurde durch den kommandeur des deutschen
kontingents vor ort die notfallpläne für
eine emergency departure ausgelöst
5347 menschen hat die bundeswehr
gerettet wie viele helfer deutschlands
zurück bleiben müssen ist nicht bekannt
der luftbrücke nicht mehr in sicherheit
gebracht werden können werden wir nicht
vergessen sondern wir werden uns weiter
um ihre ausreise bemühen dazu finden ja
auch gespräche seitens des auswärtigen
amtes insbesondere auch von einem patzer
mit den taliban statt ihre ganze ihre
letzte hoffnung setzt die deutsche
außenpolitik jetzt auf diesen diplomaten
ja schon unzähligen politikern
afghanistan erklärt hat markus poetzel
war botschafter in kabul spricht die
landessprache dari und verhandelt für
die bundesregierung mit den taliban
gestern trifft putze den taliban-führer
schierstein xe bei seinem
gesprächsmarathon in doha im golfstaat
katar danach teilt puzzle auf twitter
mit direktor steinig sein hat mir
versichert dass afghanen mit gültigen
dokumenten auch nach dem 31 august mit
linienflügen ausreisen dürfen jetzt
musste herausfinden was die taliban
dafür wollen
ich bin nicht in der haut wenigen die
jetzt verhandeln stecken denn die werden
erpresst die sind jetzt in der schwachen
position dadurch dass man nicht
rechtzeitig evakuiert hat haben die
taliban jetzt das heft des handelns und
werden die preise diktieren zwei aus
reisewege will berlin versuchen zu
öffnen der flughafen kabul soll
mittelfristig zivil betrieben werden ein
weiterer weg führt über den
nachbarstaaten afghanistans
wir werden mit unseren botschaften an
der grenze ab der grenze dafür
konsularische unterstützung leisten die
menschen die nicht evakuiert worden sind
rennen in ein ungewisses schicksal der
landweg ist unheimlich beschwerlich
gefährlich für sie da ist einfach
sozusagen das physische überleben gerade
einfach in gefahr nur der bundeswehr
kameramann darf drehen wie am abend 19
uhr 47 deutscher zeit der letzte flug
aus kabul in taschkent ankommt und so
viel zurück bleibt
professor peter neumann forscht und
lehrt zur bekämpfung von terror
organisationen am renommierten king's
college in london guten abend
genannte kleber die regierungen der usa
und europas haben sich dazu
durchgerungen mit den taliban zu reden
wie mit anderen unangenehmen regierungen
im rest der welt aber sind das überhaupt
die richtigen haben die gotteskrieger
das land unter kontrolle
das ist genau die richtige frage also
vor einer woche haben wir uns gedanken
darüber gemacht wie werden die taliban
dieses land regieren
die annahme war dass die taliban
tatsächlich die kontrolle ausüben können
jetzt eine woche später stellen wir uns
die frage sind die taliban überhaupt in
der lage dieses land zu kontrollieren
oder droht uns möglicherweise ein bürger
kriegsähnlicher zustand wie in libyen wo
es alle möglichen milizen gibt wo
internationale terroristische
organisationen unterschlupf gefunden
haben und wo die taliban so schrecklich
sie sind gar nicht mehr die
schrecklichsten sind nun haben sie schon
den dsk wie er genannt wird in ihren
kreisen die diese vorgänge erforschen
erwähnt was muss man von dieser
organisation halten sie hängt ja
offensichtlich mit dem islamischen staat
zusammen das sind aber nicht die selben
wie in syrien und was haben die gegen
die taliban fundamentalisten sind sie
beide
der es ist immer schon in afghanistan
präsent gewesen und man darf nicht
vergessen dass die präsenz der
westlichen truppen also der amerikaner
der deutschen anderer nato staaten in
den vergangenen jahren auch und vor
allem nicht nur der bekämpfung der
taliban gedient hat sondern der
bekämpfung von gruppen genau wie dem s
und die tatsache dass der westen jetzt
abgezogen ist hat es nicht nur für die
taliban einfacher gemacht sondern er hat
auch ein vakuum geschaffen das es dem s
und ähnlichen gruppen ermöglicht hat
wieder die kontrolle zu übernehmen und
das ist auch eine konsequenz des
westlichen rückzugs insofern hat auch
das nicht nur hat das nicht nur die
taliban zu verantworten sondern das hat
auch der westen zu verantworten sind die
taliban nicht im grunde ein heim gewächs
von afghanistan während der es doch eher
von außen kommt und doch möglicherweise
weniger präsenz bisher hatte und der
bevölkerung weniger verbreitet ist
richtig und das ist die antwort auf den
zweiten teil ihrer frage die taliban
sind eine islamistische organisation
aber sie sind eben auch eine
paschtunische stammes medizin wollen
einen gottesstaat aber ein gottesstaat
für die paschtunen und die sind in
afghanistan und in pakistan die taliban
haben keine globalen ambitionen der es
sieht sich selbst als kalifat als
globales weltreich der muslime und der
es hat eben auch einen
alleinvertretungsanspruch und deswegen
mögen in die taliban nicht der es sagt
dass die taliban illegitim sind man kann
nicht mit den taliban kooperieren
aussicht dass ihr es kann nur den esg
und deswegen gibt es zwischen taliban
und er es keine freundschaft im
gegenteil es gibt extreme feindschaft
die taliban haben ja inzwischen
sozusagen den griff auf die westlichen
kassen da wird ja schon in doha mächtig
verhandelt wie zum beispiel auch europa
dafür bezahlt dass man die menschen die
noch drin sind und rausholen anständig
behandelt außerdem kontrollieren die
taliban den drogenhandel das heißt wir
haben geld unterstützung sie sind
zahlreich offenbar dieser bürgerkrieg
von dem sie sprechen zwischen taliban
und dem islamischen staat hat er nicht
einen ziemlich klaren ausgang das
einfach die taliban am längeren hebel
sitzen
wir haben in den letzten 40 jahren
bürgerkrieg in afghanistan gesehen das
natürlich zu bestimmten zeitpunkten
immer bestimmte gruppen am längeren
hebel sitzen aber das für keine dieser
gruppen der hebel lang genug ist um das
land tatsächlich mit selbstbewusstsein
zu kontrollieren und meine voraussage
wäre dass die taliban natürlich in der
lage sind über große teile des landes
kontrolle auszuüben daran glaube ich
nach wie vor aber dass es signifikante
teile des landes gibt wo es nach wie vor
konflikt geben wird konflikten mit
organisationen wie dem es um mit anderen
milizen die sich bilden werden und das
ist genau der nährboden für
internationale terroristische
organisation wenn sich mal anschauen den
letzten jahren wo diese organisationen
entstanden sind dann immer in
situationen wo es keine klare situation
der kontrolle gab keine regierung in
libyen in syrien afghanistan oder im
irak und genau das befürchte ich jetzt
nach 20 jahren krieg ist ein reich
gedeckter boden bereitet worden für neue
kriege und organisationen dieser art
keine gute bilanz dankeschön peter
neumann
danke
und nun nachrichten von kai soll
berichtet der frage auf welche daten
sich künftige corona maßnahmen stützen
sollen die frage hat
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen heute
beantwortet wichtigste messlatte solle
die regionale auslastung der
krankenhäuser seien sagte er dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland dazu
kämen parameter wie infektions dynamik
und impfquoten ob sein vorschlag zum
gesetz wird muss der bundestag
entscheiden am montag hatte die
regierung entschieden dass die inzidenz
als wichtigste größe abgelöst werden
soll aktuell liegt die bundesweite
hospitalisierung 's quote wie es heißt
bei 1,56 so viele menschen pro 100000
einwohner wurden in den vergangenen
sieben tagen mit cupid 19 ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert auf dem
höhepunkt der zweiten welle ende
dezember waren es zehnmal so viele
damals war fast niemand geimpft das
robert koch institut meldete heute
außerdem zwölf
1626 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind
4226 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incidents liegt nun bei 66 binnen
eines tages kamen außerdem 21 todesfälle
dazu
wegen rechtsextremer vorfälle wurde vor
drei monaten das sek frankfurt aufgelöst
nun werden die spezialeinsatzkommandos
in ganz hessen neu geordnet das hat
innenminister beugt angekündigt sie
bleiben an ihren standorten werden aber
künftig zentral organisiert das
frankfurter sek wird personell neu
aufgestellt
seit juni ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft gegen 20 mitglieder
der ehemaligen einheit sie gehörten zu
einer chat gruppe in der
volksverhetzende inhalte und nazi
symbole geteilt wurden
die städte und gemeinden in deutschland
stehen vor einer jahrhundertaufgabe so
haben mehrere bundes- behörden eine
besorgniserregende studie auf den punkt
gebracht demnach werden unwetter mit
starkregen in deutschland immer häufiger
und intensiver so heftige wie zuletzt im
westen deutschlands würden zwar die
ausnahme bleiben doch vor allem
städtische region müssten dringend
vorsorge treffen zum beispiel durch mehr
grünflächen weil der finanzbedarf immens
sei müsse man über förderprogramme
nachdenken
es ist jetzt nur vier fünf monate her da
hatten die usa das weltweit größte
impfprogramm us fabriken von pfizer
produzierten db on pack impfstoff made
in germany in massen und dann verlor das
programm den schwung heute ist immer
noch nur die hälfte der bevölkerung
vollständig geimpft weniger als in
deutschland das liegt vor allem so
berichtet claudia benz aus washington an
republikanischen politikern und
gouverneuren die impfungen und sogar
masken für linkes teufelszeug erklären
der krankmachende effekte ihrer
realitätsverweigerung ist stärker als
die impfung die hospitalisierung rate
die jetzt auch bei uns gelten soll die
zahl der menschen die so krank sind dass
sie in die klinik gewissen lag in
deutschland in den schlimmsten wochen
bei 15 in den betroffenen us staaten
liegt sie jetzt schon bei 80 und steigt
und steigt sie wurden angeheizt von
rechten meinungsmachern und politikern
jetzt entlädt sich die ganze wut vor
allem an den schulen masken oder nicht
das ist zum bitteren kampf unter eltern
geworden wir wissen wer du bist du
kannst jetzt gehen aber wir werden dich
finden du kannst dich in der
öffentlichkeit nicht mehr blicken lassen
die polizei muss schließlich diesen
elternabend auflösen keine masken für
unsere kinder auch die jüngsten sind
teil eines machtkampfes
republikanische gouverneure haben
jedwede masken pflicht in ihren staaten
verboten für sie eine ideologische frage
keine wissenschaftliche
in florida haben die eltern das recht zu
entscheiden das gesetz habe ich
unterschrieben es wird umgesetzt wer
dagegen verstößt widersetzt sich dem
gesetz hier
[Musik]
einer von ihnen ist alberto cavallo
zuständig für die schulen des distrikts
miami date gegen die anordnung verhängt
er eine masken pflicht riskiert damit
den entzug von geldern für seine schulen
und mehr
da gibt es für mich keine kompromisse
wenn ich dafür meinen job riskieren oder
mein gehalt dann ist das ein kleiner
preis um hier auf der richtigen seite zu
stehen da bin ich völlig mit mir im
reinen und profitiert ps
unterstützung für den widerstand kommt
von ganz oben vom us-präsidenten was den
gouverneur empört
das wird doch betrieben von den
gewerkschaften es ist sehr respektlos
nicht nur gegenüber den staaten ihre
eigene politik zu machen sondern auch
gegenüber den eltern für ihre kinder die
beste entscheidung zu treffen
der ideologische kampf hier wird er real
hier ist es der kampf ums überleben
diese klinik in tampa ist so voll dass
sie patienten wegschicken an andere
kliniken die todesfälle in florida 15
mal so hoch wie anfang juli
die menge an tod und sterben die wir
hier sehen in meinem ganzen berufsleben
habe ich so etwas nicht gesehen
vor allem ungeimpfte patienten behandeln
sie hier das sind die schweren fälle und
das macht die pflegerinnen hier so
wütend vier patienten mussten sie am tag
zuvor dem bestatter übergeben
ich möchte das nicht tun wir hätten
diese kurve quelle vermeiden können wenn
einfach mehr menschen sich hätten
zweimal impfen lassen
aber viele sind durch den politischen
streit völlig verunsichert wissen nicht
wem sie noch glauben sollen lassen sich
deswegen nicht impfen der streit um
masken um impfungen und pflichten geht
jetzt vor den gerichten weiter
schauen wir auf die wirtschaft
bahnreisende müssen sich wohl auf neue
streiks einstellen denn im tarifstreit
mit der lokführergewerkschaft will der
konzern vorerst kein neues angebot
vorlegen die hand sei ausgestreckt sagte
bahn chef lutz dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland inhaltlich sei man nicht
weit voneinander entfernt daher seien
die bisherigen streiks völlig unnötig
gewesen
seit heute hat auch die anstehende
tarifrunde beim öffentlichen dienst ein
preisschild verdi und beamtenbund
fordern für die beschäftigten der länder
fünf mehr geld mindestens aber 150 euro
im monat im gesundheitswesen sogar
mindestens 300 hessen verhandelt auch
dieses mal separat
keine gute zeiten für häuslebauer sie
müssen immer tiefer in die tasche
greifen so sind die preise für bauland
auch 2020 gestiegen auf einen
durchschnittlichen rekordwert allerdings
gibt es da enorme unterschiede stephanie
beckert das ist richtig traditionell
kraft ja zwischen stadt und land lagen
eine große preisspanne und seitdem viele
deutsche in der korona krise die vorzüge
des ländlichen raums für sich entdeckt
haben sind auch dort die preise für
bauland gestiegen neben den
galoppierenden baukosten entwickeln sich
nun auch die grundstückskosten zum
preistreiber auf dem wohnungsmarkt seit
2010 kletterten die preise für bauland
von durchschnittlich 130 euro auf rund
200 euro pro quadratmeter
unter den flächenländern war bayern das
teuerste pflaster im stadtstaat hamburg
mussten käufer noch mal deutlich mehr
zahlen
in sachsen-anhalt dagegen zahlt man mit
durchschnittlich 46 euro pro
quadratmeter nur einen bruchteil davon
billige kredite mit zum teil hohen
darlehenssummen haben die spekulation
mit bauland in den vergangenen jahren
befeuert verbände drängen seit langem
kommunen zum handeln möglicherweise
bewegt sich da auch jetzt etwas mit
hilfe des kürzlich beschlossenen
gesetzes zur mobilisierung von bauland
es erleichtert den kommunen bauland zu
schaffen in dem es vorkaufsrechte
ausweitet bau gebote verschärft und
bebauungspläne beschleunigt
beschleunigung ist denn auch das
stichwort auch dieses gesetz muss erst
umgesetzt werden bis es wirkung zeigt
das kann in deutschland mit seinen 16
verschiedenen bauch verordnungen noch
ein weilchen dauern danke an die
frankfurter börse
seit wochen brennen im amerikanischen
westen die wälder inzwischen an 92 orten
im südkalifornischen san bernardino hat
nun ein feuer dutzende häuser zerstört
und 1000 anwohner sollen sich sicherheit
bringen etwas weiter nördlich in der
sierra nevada wütet das sogenannte
kalldorf feuer vernichtete zeitweise
fast 400 hektar wald pro stunde und
bedrohte mehr als 17.000 gebäude
ja wir haben eine für so einen tag
relativ positive meldungen aus
afghanistan es heißt jetzt aus
glaubwürdiger quelle dass die große
explosion kurz vor beginn unserer
sendung eine explosion war die
amerikanische truppen benutzt haben um
große munitions bestände in die luft zu
jagen und unbrauchbar zu machen das war
also geplant und organisiert
das war es zunächst von uns an einem
abend an dem sich die nachrichtenlage
alle minute ändern kann um 1 uhr
berichtet das heute-journal update dann
den aktuellen stand
[Musik]
guten abend die kaltfront von tief nick
hat inzwischen die alpen überquert
danach gab es dieses typische
schauerwetter und das wird uns auch in
den nächsten tagen begleiten denn das
tief nicht so richtig von polen zu uns
rein das hoch bei ja dagegen das bleibt
über den britischen inseln und hat auf
unser wetter eigentlich nur ganz wenig
einfluss so haben wir es also mit vielen
regenschauern auch jetzt in der nacht zu
tun und am ehesten trocken bleibt die
nacht zwischen dem sauerland der mosel
und dem schwarzwald der winter zu kommt
aus nordwestlichen bis nördlichen
richtungen und die temperaturen sinken
auf 7 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen bis auf 8 grad am
alpenrand sonst geht auf 12 bis 9 grad
runter und nur auf den ostfriesischen
inseln und direkt an der nordsee bleibt
es bei 15 grad milder erwärmt dann noch
das wasser morgen hier in die
höchsttemperaturen in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen niedriger als die
nachttemperaturen an der nordsee da
werden nämlich nur 13 grad erreicht
sonst gibt es 15 bis 19 und am oberrhein
vielleicht mal 20 grad morgen geht es
eher noch mehr regen schauer und kurze
gewitter als heute die sonne tut sich da
schwer im norden weht dazu ein recht
kräftiger wind aus nordwestlichen
richtungen im westen ist es ein nord
west und dem süden ein westwind und am
freundlichsten wird morgen wohl am
oberrhein da scheint häufiger mal die
sonne in den nächsten tagen geht es sehr
wechselhaft weiter und die temperaturen
werden sich wahrscheinlich erst anfang
der kommenden woche ein bisschen
steigern guten abend